I'm Laurie Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight thanks so much
for joining us all right they're
dropping like flies Hunter Biden lost
another attorney he didn't misplace it
the guy quit so what's going on we'll
examine that in moments but first
with the track record of abysmal failure
for black Americans Democrats now see
that there's real risk of declining
support from that constituency that they
once thought would never abandon them so
how do they Shore up the black base
support tougher criminal laws in the
inner cities after all violence is
affecting black Americans the most
Or democrats revisiting their slavish
Devotion to the teachers unions who are
adamantly opposed to school choice
Americans especially minorities stuck in
bad public schools now have no options
or is Biden finally going to let up on
the climate Madness and bring the cost
of energy down
well the answers to all of the above are
no no and no
Democrats agree to any of that when they
could just call Republicans racist
women have seen Donald Trump use a word
that rhymes with a racial epithet and
that's been adapted and adopted on
extremist sites to refer to blacks this
week he used a word that rhymes with the
n-word in one of his posts
okay they won't even say the word the
word is like rigged election rigor does
that mean going forward no one should
use the phrase trigger warning either
that's the case what are liberals gonna
do
and remember the Democrats can always
count on the press to help fan the
Flames of racial division as well
because if one wacko threatens one judge
who happens to be black then the Press
is going to say essentially all Trump
supporters are racist too Eugene
Robinson in the Washington Post writing
that it was always just a matter of time
before threats against the public
officials holding Trump accountable
became explicitly violent and racist
now why was it just a matter of time
because in Robinson's warp thinking
supporting Trump is akin to supporting
cross burning
that's just disgusting they never had
such concerns about Kavanaugh when he
was threatened and when these cynical
ploys don't work other professor gets
pick up the slack trying to argue for a
type of self-segregation or in fact the
creation of black States the well-known
Progressive Charles blow argues for
greater black power through migration
but he doesn't seem to understand why
black migration Southward has already
occurred because like other Americans
black Americans are moving to greener
pastures or I should say redder pastures
where crime isn't tolerated and the
economy is actually vibrant I believe
that if black people simply return to
the South they could significantly
increase their own political power which
has the potential to not only up in the
politics of that region but also of the
country as a whole there is no way to
truly have power in the country if you
do not also have access to state
power so crowd all black people into one
state I I don't understand this argument
at all and as I said black Americans are
already migrating Southward
as a liberal Mr blow undoubtedly thinks
that state measures such as reparations
the teaching of CRT and higher taxes
would help black Americans
of course we're already seeing though
aren't we where that path leads in
States like California they're on the
precipice of doing some type of
reparations
and it's all a disaster there and of
course Mr blow implies that anyone who
takes issue with his ideas is a racist
freak out when I say that I believe that
some states should be majority black
but I always ask them this question why
are you not freaking out that every
state but Hawaii is at least a plurality
white and that there are seven or eight
states where 90 plus percent
of the population
is majority one
oh first of all people aren't calling
for majority white States that's one
reason Charles of course all of this
rhetoric encourages more separation of
the races and less integration people
actually getting along getting to know
each other now this is a sentiment we've
heard before though a New York City
council member this was a few years ago
actually celebrated when he lost white
residents
I have the distinct honor to be able to
come before you and say I actually lost
white population in my community
I lost them
they left so if you see one or two or
three or four or five whites in my
neighborhood they're passing through
that's what militant radicals actually
think they believe that their own racism
is Justified they're
urging their young people to stay
separate don't trust white people
because of course white people they
believe are extinctively racist just
like the entire system of law
enforcement even when cops are
minorities themselves The Genesis of
back to Blue came out as a sort of
collective conservative response to the
black lives matter movement there is an
Implement an implicit race racial and
racist thread that runs through this
sort of Confederacy of people
oh my God she
Lord help that woman and you know what
else is racist the broken windows theory
of policing and the idea that you
actually lock criminals up
Giuliani lost his first race from Aaron
York but he succeeded the second time
around after embracing some of the
ugliest most demagogic racist politics
that Donald Trump would later mine to
great effect as mayor Giuliani oversaw
an incredible increase in the
surveillance and policing of black and
brown New Yorkers the truth is everyone
including African Americans had a better
quality of life in New York when Rudy
was mayor it's not racist to say that
things were safer because the streets
were safer
and white liberals now claiming that
Rudy's policies were racist are lying
Law and Order is not racist it's common
sense
but common sense is out the window with
today's Democrats especially where black
voters are concerned
with the horrid record on the economy
the Border crime all bidens boosters can
do now is dangle a shiny racial division
object in front of African Americans
imagine having such little respect for
the intelligence of your own base hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else